on this spark at 6/8 primarily a small
photo of a shooting guard
[Applause]
[Applause]
things will slam it in it all up just to
find the open man unselfish place those
ears good it comes in the game kicks it
back out pains we're gonna get it to Kai
Reed off with nice pass luck I love
y'all fault movement of Kyrie I love to
swag in his step more features we're
gonna take it to canter
earlier in the game to be an exceptional
cutter in this league goodbye by our
perfect ball for food fake kicks it to
the corner hey with open stop sit down
I'm just gonna say they play like that i
spaced on the inc bounce to set up a
bucket of over the hole
[Applause]
or a great cut great pass and finish
concentrate shooting the ball on the
offensive end
foul committed by Marcus Martin Boston
finding some rhythm of it perfect
Celtics - four - that gets one for one
shoot three so far
Oh nicely done Jordan hey wait are you
receiving it alright let's go back to
the Gordon Hayward
alley-oop nice play well you know
Fitzsimmons still haven't hit three yet
either either point guard Tampa -
then when that play a lot and we try an
answer on the other end short with the
three rebound picked off Horford fights
Kyrie two three
[Applause]
offensive rebound baris comes away with
it
Kairi throwing it up for Horford outside
Haywood a three
a word
[Applause]
Boston is within four
[Music]
it has passed hey somebody's got the
feeling from orphans
yeah nice play by out warped
[Music]
[Applause]
Orford Horford all-defensive team a
season ago boy the Sixers turn it over
again huh and he was open back out to
Marcus smart from D Irving gets it back
to balls bird hoped a good look
underneath his smart hesitates gets two
and foul players are so sensitive
agents are so sensitive and management
in tandem with the dunk on the baseline
his first field goal of the game
interesting point towns with the
mid-range jump shot I know you're
sitting there oh he didn't people will
tell you that Al Horford is sort of the
hub of their office they're using it the
G League as a lab and using a shot and
possession is a penalty for that
intentional foul beautiful look by
Horford to brown on the Flex cut yeah
like managed to nobody like that
I'm a huge potato to to
get out Horford cut potatoes solid
finish off it again working sabonis nice
great class tomorrow
look at that baseline pleat itself keep
executing off its lead and to stretch
this lead
like that
was wide open on this play we got his
bearings and then Jason Tate him with
the hard cut me have a cut was so good
just our BIOS way we could finish on the
baseline hope it keeps me alive and
we'll want to make it knocks down a
three
desperation shot doesn't go Whiteside
there though with the offensive glass
that's rejected it picked off by Horford
[Applause]
I'll walk around the defensive in
white.i gets aboard there's two block
and they're off to the races and watch
Kyrie at the last minute start to
accelerate through the rim we got away
from the defense right hand spin it off
the glass to Connor it's bound to
anytime
roasting guys out when they're cutting
is flashing from the ringside little
two-man game was bored and Tatum great
cut by Kyrie Bella
Wow glad we told you now very very
improved three-point shooting 9 points
and Kyrie adding two more to his total
great show by Deng Adel as well to slow
down Rozier mark on the back door cuts
as he had the size advantage good foot
movement by the rookie hopefully giving
a little bit of room inside Hayward
their unselfish aren't thing get it well
that's what they do to us actually
there's Taylor
three plays in that's all we're going to
write those three plays over and over
right now not paying attention or for
trying state them open for three there
comes off looking the shoot there but
they get the switch and great cut by
Moore's terrific read by Horford there
you talked about getting to a forfeit
their activity he got it and makes the
play seven-point lead inside Morris to
he lead changes in the games another one
of these crew in here tonight
stayed off the Horford fee
[Applause]
position Down Goes Middleton pireas down
saves the ball nice hustle by Irving
Horford here comes smart
the Raptors in town he slams it
Horford he gets the switch there there's
another nice pass as it they are attack
it again that's a before I guess cousins
they give it which in a hard cut by
attained Amir Kevin again you know I've
said it before you see boogie looking at
the post feed Kings now 4 of 6 from 3/5
in the league at 37.5 as Tatum goes in
over Cory Brewers like Kevin Durant
quiet landed career with they could be
big table difference makers if the team
is fortunate enough to get him away from
where they are guarding what Alexander
the rookie is short on the jumper
Celtics off and running Wow Belfast
Irene
by Al ho that's unbelievable for your
Center on the team to recognize that
Celtics trailing by one ice dime to
Kyrie for the layout
[Music]
Kyrie for free routes the tree my bleep
Boston
Tim decides to take it and knock down
three
[Applause]
bades open misses the shot rebound
controlled by Alford sounds good a
second opportunity over the top made by
Kyrie
nice pants good look by Horford by
Horford four rebounds for Horford in the
game bounce pass a beauty Haywood for
[Applause]
240 to go till halftime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Horford with four to shoot
lots it inside Baines is open and it
easy to yeah well we have two teams that
averaged 26 assists Kirby
perfect Morris open for three and out to
town
young is there that says working and
that's the profit part wouldn't I
[Applause]
7:4 didn't play last year pace was
injured second year that's Pat's outside
Brown which free in a Wofford late Susan
how Turner number two in this
communication Turner should have switch
right there and wide open lane Tyree
preaching in hand provider
Tatum the punch and the Celtics trying
to pull what advice for his teammate Al
Horford who's been knocking down shots
Austin basketballs nice look inside
Irving caught Hill napkin and now you
gotta say to pass set watching Kim's
right in you don't plan the top till the
basket by shuttle kettle three does not
count off the foul a nice pass back door
and Heyward with the dunk mom whenever
they play together they get whatever
they want
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content